this is Terrorism on a scale unknown and
it is directed not only against Israel
so we gained sympathy but we knew that
it would dissipate and uh that we had so
so much time uh to take action and now
the dissipation is taking place because
of the
inevitability of the situation on the
ground when the Hamas is taking the
civilian population of Gaza as as human
shelters there are hiding behind and
they are exposing them and in our desire
not to have civilians hurt in a future
engagement we have there has been some
displacement of Palestinians and
humanitarian concerns came to the for
all these has to be dealt with and
clearly we have to be very careful but
we have to manage a war we have to
accomplish this destruction of Hamas
once and for all